Fuentes consultadas para este reporte me
afirman que la presidenta Dina boluarte
estaría evaluando las estrategias a
seguir para que el congreso de Perú
defina El adelanto de las elecciones la
más importante de ellas sería enviar al
Primer Ministro Alberto tarola al
congreso para que haga cuestión de
confianza y pida al poder legislativo
que defina el adelanto electoral en el
caso extremo que el congreso de este
país niegue dos pedidos de confianza la
presidenta Dina boluarte queda
facultalmente capacitada para disolver
el congreso y ella misma convocar a un
adelanto de las elecciones para este
2023 algunos analistas coinciden en que
esta sería la única salida para que
Paulo arte saque adelante de la Reforma
que visto por todos el parlamento
peruano no tiene voluntad de atender
desoyendo el pedido de los peruanos en
especial los manifestantes que tienen en
jaque a este país con los bloqueos y las
protestas que han ocasionado la muerte
de más de 50 personas y también han
producido más de mil quinientos heridos
en Francisco Seguiremos la semana
política a nivel institucional a partir
del próximo lunes pero por otro lado la
presidenta también ordenó a la policía y
al ejército que desbloqueen las vías
Cuál es el estado de las protestas y las
perspectivas también de este movimiento
ciudadano en Perú
Bueno le cuento que el último reporte de
la superintendencia nacional de
transporte relata que existen 83 puntos
de tránsito interrumpidos y 16 vidas
Nacionales con los bloqueos expertos en
seguridad con los que he conversado me
señalan que en este momento las fuerzas
armadas y la policía se encuentran
desarrollando labores e inteligencia
para que esta información les permita
realizar un desbloqueo de vías con la
menor número de heridos y tratando de
que no haya muertos después de esto
ellos van a realizar el operativo de
despeje de las vías que están bloqueadas
Mientras tanto muchas regiones del Perú
están sufriendo el desabastecimiento de
alimentos y combustibles al respecto el
ministro de economía Alex Contreras ha
revelado que producto de toda este clima
de incertidumbre violencia protestas El
Perú ha perdido más de 25 16 millones de
dólares y va a ser muy difícil que la
economía de esta nación vuelva a
remontar en su situación que estaba de
crecimiento económico